howdy-ho reject nation Greg Alba yeah
sure we are going to watch the teaser
trailer for shame blogs the predator
before we do that patron of the day
shout out to Mikael linden he is a
fairly new patronage act he is actually
from a small village in Sweden and the
past couple times I talked to him it's a
lot about his enthusiasm for Sweden and
he's even been encouraging me to go on
vacation there and he wanted me to
encourage all you guys it's most of our
subscribers from America to take a look
in Sweden because it's apparently a
beautiful place to vacation a lot of
great musical artists come from there
and more importantly mikael comes from
there he is just a very very lovely
kind-hearted human being so thank you so
much Mikael for joining the patreon page
we're gonna come to Sweden and we're
gonna cuddle with you oh yeah we're
gonna put on some ABBA
it's gonna be great
idly here it's not Christmas
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so the kid some illustration did you see
anything unusual something to learn the
pieces
[Music]
I think they're attempting hybridization
we need to know if you pose a threat
we're assassins isn't posing a threat
looks like they're taking a page at a
Requiem surprise it's kind of an
underwhelming trailer in southern
analysis after all the hype of waiting
for a teaser trailer for so long
honestly when I was watching this
trailer I kind of feel like this is a
miss marketed trailer already I think
what they're trying to do is remind us
of the predator franchise and what it's
become for those hardcore predator fans
and I think what people have been
wanting it to do is kind of harken back
a little bit more similar to the first
predator which it doesn't look like it's
doing No
and then on top of that this is Shane
Black's movie you get a hint of humor in
that one moment really saw something you
know and I've read one thing of what
Thomas Jane talked about and other
people have talked about how there's
gonna be a lot of that Shane black style
and humor in this film and I just don't
think they know how to market it yet
it's just a teaser trailer so I think
what they're trying to capitalize on is
like horror action I just don't think
that's gonna be the exact tone of this
movie what this teaser trailer is
communicating I think that's why it
feels a little bit off and the way this
is marketed because I have a strong
impression that the vibe will feel very
much different not alike when Shane
black did Iron Man 3 and then we got a
completely totally different motif of
the kid you know playing with the part
of the the big like gauntlet thing was
was cool and that's sort of about it I
mean like I'm excited about the cast you
know you get this
yeah Augen guy doing the Logan character
yeah yeah I didn't really get much
personality or much flavor and I thought
they could have like tease or hyped up
the predator a little better I really
don't think it's the actual movie like I
feel like some people might actually
look at this try to go this movie's
looks like a cheesy 90s action flick or
something cuz that's like the flat or
something yeah that's kind of the vibe
the trailers giving I really think that
the movies gonna be a lot better than
what the trailers marketing at the
movies projects expect this movie to be
a lot more I guess pleasing or
or satisfying like I feel like Shane
black probably really knows what people
want it's not hard to tell like doing
another earth predator movie might be a
little bit of it's all order after
Requiem left yeah add tasted people's
meds like in a small town and yeah it
did have that Requiem look hey I wasn't
expecting to flash back there the
predator getting hybrid technology
upgrades it seems a little bit cheesy
see I feel like there's gonna be a sense
of humor about it that this trailers not
communicating so instead it comes across
cheesy don't worry the next trailer
they're gonna show a whole different
thing we're like believers gonna start
playing they're good yeah there's the
whole squad of assassins of a magic
dragon song look you got sterling can't
browning a keegan-michael key and Thomas
Jane Thomas Jane to any olivia munn
furniture design looks pretty cool I
mean it looks it looks like modern-day
like slight upgrade to it I mean the
cinematography looks cool and it's a
predator movie and I don't really don't
know how people are responding to this
trailer and what the pressure franchise
has evolved into after the first great
one I really don't think it has a bar
too high to hit I just really hope we
get likes gonna be good I think this
movie will be a lot more fun have a lot
more personality within what we
currently got and it's just a teaser so
hopefully the official trailer give this
a much better taste alright guys well
what did you think of this predator
teaser trailer it was a bit of a letdown
did you like it wasn't exactly what you
expected put your comments down below
you guys can subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification bell for
subscribe buttons don't really work and
check us on patreon full-length TV show
reactions weekly Q&A is a lot of stuff
come check us out